[Música]
[Aplausos]
muchas veces del estrés trató de
sabotear mi vida en diferentes momentos
y situaciones y en algunos casos casi lo
logra hoy estoy aquí para decirles para
contarles y para invitarles sobre un
método maravilloso que en mi caso siento
que transformó mi vida de muchas formas
y en todas las muchas áreas de mi vida
se trata del mindfulness hace poco más
de 8 años empecé a descubrirlo empecé a
experimentarlo hacerlo y enseñarlo y
resultó ser que descubrí un mundo
maravilloso en donde hoy puedo decirles
aquí una vida relax es posible el
mindfulness que significa en español
significa conciencia plena y es un
método neurocientífico súper fácil
adaptable a todos nuestros estilos de
vida que nos enseña con diferentes
ejercicios a manejar nuestros niveles de
estrés a estar presente a sosegarnos a
estar consciente de todas nuestras
emociones nos enseña a estar presente en
el aquí y en el ahora este nuestro único
momento cuando lleguéis al y ese momento
ya no está cuantas veces estamos
viviendo en el pasado que ya no nos
pertenece o que ya se fue o estamos
solos enfocados
futuro que aún no llega y necesitamos de
la energía y del enfoque que el
mindfulness no se entrena y nos ayuda
para vivir en este eterno presente por
otro lado resulta hacer que la
organización mundial de la salud decretó
el estrés como la nueva epidemia global
y ante esa mirada pues les quiero contar
de que necesitamos tomar conciencia y
entender que tu bienestar no es un lujo
es una necesidad real pues en este
caminar y en este descubrir entendí que
estaba presente en muchas empresas como
bien dije en muchas áreas de la vida a
nivel corporativo a nivel educativo a
nivel médico a nivel de los niños a
nivel de embarazadas lo he trabajado con
muchas personas y es maravilloso y
fascinante por supuesto para mi asombro
cuando empecé a estudiar y hacer lo
propio entendí que empresas gigantescas
como la nasa google
starbucks proctor and gamble nike hb o
yahoo y muchísimas otras a niveles
también centros oncológicos y colegios
en todos lados del mundo lo están
implementando y utilizando
para que para tener un bienestar laboral
un bienestar personal un bienestar real
en donde entendamos que tu bienestar y
tu realidad no es un lujo es una
necesidad y autogestionarnos y cuáles
son las herramientas respiración
meditación ejercicios súper prácticos
está disponible para todos en todas las
edades y en todas las áreas de nuestra
vida es mi invitación y ese es el cuento
que yo de vida tengo porque me atrevo a
decir que en verdad salvó mi vida y la
ha transformado de muchas maneras vivir
en conciencia plena en tu eterno y ahora
yo les quiero decir que todos estos
procesos y todos los beneficios de este
manejo del estrés de sosegar no de
manejar la atención insomnio etcétera
están a la mano de todos nosotros pero
todo proceso es de ti para ti y contigo
y recordarnos que nosotros atraemos lo
que pensamos y nos convertimos en lo que
sentimos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]